In the last lecture, we saw what is an
electric current and in this lecture, we
will understand what do we mean by
conventional current and electron
current. And to understand these two
currents, I have taken one arrangement.
In this arrangement, you can see three
things. The first one
is the battery. The second one is the
bulb and the third one is the copper
wire we are using to connect battery and
the bulb. Now, to understand what is
actually happening in this circuit, I
will magnify this portion of the copper
wire.
And after magnifying this portion of the
copper wire, we can clearly see the free
electrons present in the copper wire.
Free electrons are present in the copper
wire because copper is a metal and most
of you must have seen this type of
diagram in many books where a battery is
connected to a wire with high
cross-sectional area using the wire with
a low cross-sectional area. But, this is
not true. We are not using a wire with
high cross-sectional area. The
cross-sectional area of this wire and
this wire is same. We have simply
magnified this portion of the wire to
understand the movement of electrons and
now we will focus on how electrons are
drifted in this particular arrangement.
You can see battery's positive terminal
is connected to the copper wire and then
copper wire is connected to one terminal
of the bulb. Then, the other terminal of
the bulb is connected to the negative
terminal of the battery. So, in this
way, the circuit is complete and
therefore, there will be a current
through the bulb and therefore bulb will
not glow. Now, due to the positive
terminal of the battery, the electrons
present in the copper wire will be
drifted towards the positive terminal
because we know electrons are negatively
charged and therefore they will be
attracted towards the positive terminal
of the battery. So, electrons will move
in this direction and in the last
lecture we saw the flow of electrons or
the movement of electrons is known as
the electric current because movement or
flow of charge is the electric current
and in this case the charge is carried
by the electrons. Therefore, flow of
electrons will constitute a current
which is known as electron current. And
the direction of electron current
is same as the flow of electrons.
Therefore, we are calling the current as
electron current and we will represent
it by I dash.
So, I dash is equal
to the current known as
electron
current and this current is due to the
flow of electrons and therefore we call
it
natural current as well.
It is also known as natural
current. It is natural current because
it is due to the actual flow of the
electrons which are the reason of the
current in this circuit. And the
electron current in this circuit is in
anticlockwise direction. And one thing
you can notice, electron current is
entering the positive terminal and it is
leaving
the negative terminal. Now, we will talk
about the another current which is known
as conventional current. In earlier
days, people assumed the flow of current
is due to the movement of positive
charges, but later on, they came to know
that the flow of current is mainly due
to the movement of electrons. But, as
the convention was there, we have
a conventional current which I will
represent by I, and the conventional
current is having the direction opposite
to that of electron current. So, in this
circuit, the conventional current will
leave the positive terminal, and it will
enter the negative terminal. So, current
I will leave the positive terminal, and
the current I will enter the negative
terminal. This is a very important point
because throughout our analysis, we are
going to use
conventional
current.
And conventional current is in the
direction of electric field. You can
note down this point that conventional
current is in
the direction
of electric
field.
Now, we will quickly revise conventional
current and electron current.
Conventional current is the current
which is due to the positive charges
movement, or you can say it is the
current which is in the direction of
electric field, and this is the current
we are going to use throughout in this
course. And by the positive charge, we
do not mean the holes present in the
semiconductor
because we are talking about the metals,
and in metals, holes are not present.
Now, on the other hand, electron current
or natural current is in the direction
of movement of negative charge, or we
can say electrons, because we will
mainly deal with electrons. So, I hope
you now understand what do we mean by
electron current or natural current and
conventional current. Now, even if you
forget what do we mean by electron
current, it is okay, but it is not okay
to forget what do we mean by
conventional current, because throughout
the circuit analysis, we are going to
use conventional current.
Now, we will move to the next point, and
in this point, I will explain how the
current value will change by reversing
the direction of the current. And to
understand this point, let's take one
copper wire. This copper wire is the
part of some electrical circuit, and
through this copper wire,
there is
a current flowing from left to right,
and the current is equal to 5 A.
Now, if we assume the current is flowing
from right to left, then this current
will be equal to -5 A.
So, when we reverse the direction of the
current, negative sign will come, or you
can say negative sign will reverse the
direction of the current. This is also
one important point, because it will be
used a lot. Now, we will move on to the
homework problem. In this homework
problem, there is a copper wire, you can
see in the figure, and in the wire,
electrons are moving from left to right.
So, electrons are moving from left to
right. This is the direction of movement
of electrons, and you need to determine
I1 and I2 when current due to the
movement of electron is equal to 2
milliampere.
I1 is having the direction from left to
right and I2 is having the direction
from right to left and because of the
movement of electrons the current is
equal to 2 milliampere.
So try to solve this question and once
you have the values of I1 and I2 don't
forget to post it in comment section. So
this is all for this lecture. I will end
it here. See you in the next one.